Alex Works Nazi as far as pound for
pound is number one in the world as far
as straight skill set is by far the best
145 around the planet he's also the
second best if not the best lightweight
on the planet how about that he went Toe
to Toe with makachev nobody asking if
muck shove that fight I think he beats
anybody else at 155 not in a market Jeff
that mocktail fights tough I think he
can't get over on him but you know I
just think at 45 there's just the guys
can't compete that wasn't even a fight
by the way guys that was even a
fight and that's why you're coming off
that Cobain event with pantosia brand
Moreno this epic fight the two best in
the world that's how those fights should
go very competitive one guy's good at
grappling Jiu Jitsu other guys boxing is
exceptional and then you got to figure
out the game plan but one guy has
success this round the other guy has
success this round goes back and forth
It's A War it's one of the fights of the
year but in this case there's not a guy
on this planet volkanasi is gonna fight
that's gonna give him a tough fight it's
just not possible hate to tell you guys